Morning, John
I am a bit worn out on philosophical musings and to tell you the truth, a bit worn out in general.
Planning conferences is hard.
So today, instead of thinking too much about things that people usually don't think very much about,
I'm just gonna tell you the fascinating tale of Phineas Gage.
In 1848, Phineas Gage was a hard-working, well-liked construction foreman working on the railroad.
He was helping to blow up the side of a mountain so that they could run a railroad through it.
And this is something he'd been doing for quite a long time.
You drill a hole into a rock and you put some blasting powder in there
and then you put some sand in there to pack it down,
then you pack it down with this rock.
So Phineas was doing this
and then someone distracted him.
And I don't know what it was, the distraction.
Maybe it was a raccoon,
maybe it was a hot girl walking down the railway.
But when Phineas came back to his work,
he did not realize that he had not put the sand in,
and so he shoved his little rod down the hole,
creating a spark,
and the blasting powder ignited
and his iron rod landed EIGHTY FEET AWAY.
Unfortunately, there was something in between that hole and whatever it was that was 80 feet away
and that thing
was Phineas Gage's head.
The rod went through about, about here
and came out like here.
And now, those of you who do not know this story are expecting the story to end,
because where could the story go from there?
Well,
three minutes later, Phineas Gage regained consciousness,
started talking to people,
walked over to a cart,
got in the cart,
sat up for the three-quarter mile travel back to his house,
waited there for a doctor and then, when the doctor finally got there,
they chatted about it.
The doctor took some wonderful written notes,
which we have copies of and I'm going to share some of that with you,
though you may not want to listen if you're a little bit squeamish.
The doctor wrote,
"I did not believe Mr. Gage's statement at the time,
but thought he was deceived.
Mr. Gage persisted in saying that the rod went through his head.
Mr. Gage got up and vomited,
the effort of the vomiting pushed out about
half a teacupful of brain,
which fell onto the floor."
The unit of measurement "teacupful" has- has since fallen out of use but, but, it's roughly--
WAY TOO MUCH BRAIN.
At that same visit Phineas said to the doctor that he hoped he wasn't much hurt.
To which the doctor presumably replied,
"uhhh."
In the coming weeks, Gage would drop in and out of a coma caused by hemorrhaging in his brain.
His family was assured that there was no possible way that he could live, which is also backed up by,
y'know, reason,
and they had his coffin and his burial clothes all ready
and then, two months after the accident,
Phineas Gage was walking around,
talking,
basically a normal guy.
He wasn't quite normal,
he wasn't quite the Phineas Gage that everyone had come to know and love,
but on the whole, a lot healthier than you would expect from a guy who had lost
several teacupfuls of brain.
So because of his behavioral problems, Phineas Gage did lose his construction job,
but PT Barnum, not to miss a weirdo,
found this guy and his iron rod and
Phineas did a little tour of the circuses, earning some money that way.
His psychological problems began to subside.
He started holding down good jobs.
And eventually, he moved to Chile to become a long-distance stagecoach driver,
in a place where people didn't know that he was Phineas Gage.
Twelve years after the accident, late-onset epilepsy set in,
which is very common in these kinds of injuries,
and Phineas's health declined until he finally died.
But the man had a three and a half foot long rod of iron
pass through his head
at hundreds of miles per hour.
And he was pretty much okay for twelve years.
A final footnote to this bizarre tale:
In 2009, a couple, who loved to collect old photographs of people,
were scanning their collection and uploading it to the photo-sharing website, flickr.
They uploaded a picture that they called, "The Whaler",
thinking that it was an injured whaler with his harpoon.
Flickr quickly told them that there was no way that that big shaft of iron was any kind of harpoon.
But no one had any suggestions about what else it could be,
until somebody commented, saying,
"You know, you may have a picture of Phineas Gage there,
and if you do
It's the only picture of Phineas Gage that exists."
And that's one more reason why I love the internet!
Because it was the only picture of Phineas Gage.
So John,
BEHOLD
Phineas Gage,
the only man to have ever had an iron rod passed through his skull at hundreds of miles per hour,
and live to tell the tale.
I'll see you on Wednesday.